we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
this number anytime that you get the
urge to leave me a message two one nine
two david p here's a voicemail that came
in in the wee hours of this morning hey
David I noticed that the ride is very
concerned with like the
over-representation of liberals among
college professors but I don't know if
any studies have been done on this but
it changed and we be concerned about the
political leanings of law enforcement I
feel like they probably leaned heavier
right and perhaps that could be playing
into the whole unarmed black got people
getting killed thing not sure so listen
this this is actually a pretty clever in
ass to point and I know that there will
be people who say oh he would he jumped
the shark when he talked about the
killing of black people let's put that
aside right cuz we've explored that in
in statistical detail before when the
right observes the heavy presence of
liberal voices in Institutes of higher
learning colleges and universities in
many departments they all of a sudden
almost want like an affirmative action
right they say no no no we actually need
more conservative voices in some of
these fields and if you dared to say
well is it possible that something about
the nature of those fields makes
progressive individuals gravitate
towards them naturally in other words is
there a sort of free-market which is
pulling in more left-wing
anthropologists and philosophy
professors or whatever the right doesn't
seem pleased with that and at the same
time when you look at law enforcement
and there are plenty of progressive and
left-wing and moderate democratic
individuals in law enforcement many many
of them there's no question that law
enforcement does skew to the right when
you point that out the right will give
the exact same defense that the left
often gives of the higher education
they'll say now listen by its very
nature if you're for order and if your
further rule of law and if you like
carrying around a gun right on whatever
level you want to make the argument
there might be some reason in which the
free market dictates that more
conservative minded individuals will
gravitate towards positions in law
enforcement we don't
we can law enforcement by mandating that
there be more progressives in law
enforcement well isn't that what you
would be doing by mandating that there
be more conservatives in philosophy
departments just asking the question if
there's a difference please explain it
to me I would love to understand what
that difference is we have a great bonus
show for you today Robert DeNiro got a
standing ovation yesterday at the Tony
Awards for saying F Trump we'll talk
about that what we think about it we
will also talk about a study which
points out that blue districts on
average in the United States have a
higher degree of income inequality than
red districts liberal versus
conservative districts of course and we
will also talk about a man who has been
given only seventy-five dollars after
being wrongly imprisoned for 31 years is
anything being done about it and also
big thing I announced that now we have
for patrons at the five dollar or higher
level and for all David Pakman show
members we have a massive discount code
for all gear at david pakman.com slash
gear I'm gonna be announcing that coupon
code today on the bonus show very very
exciting all of those stories and more
access the bonus show by becoming a
member at join pakman.com save 40% with
the coupon code vote soon 18 and of
course you can also get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a patron
at patreon.com forward slash david
pakman show thanks for being with us we
will talk to you on the bonus show or if
you're not a member
brand new program tomorrow